so far her great accomplishment has been
to you know um
well and also she has well
one thing she did was well she goes on
national tv she says things are getting
better at the border without evidence
that anything's getting better at the
border
so there's new polling and what does it
show it shows that joe biden has not won
any additional support since the
election now you could say well joe
biden had a good level of support in the
election right i mean
he won seven million more votes than his
opponent he went about 52 percent of the
vote
but normally when presidents enter
office when they first win especially
after a very very polarizing era they
enter with these very high approval
ratings
and if they get a lot done over the
first 100 days those approval ratings
tend to rise
and this happened with barack obama he
entered office he won
he won something like 53 to 45. and
then his approval rating shot up into
the 70s at the very beginning of his
presidency
and then pretty quickly they started to
come down as people realized that
what they were promised namely a
unifying figure who was post-political
and also post-racial
was lying to them during the campaign
and you saw barack obama's numbers start
to take a nosedive so he ended up in the
low 50s for most of his presidency
and that again was largely attributable
to the fact that he was a very popular
person even though his policies weren't
particularly popular
as evidenced by the fact that he lost
congress two years in well joe biden is
not nearly as personally popular as
barack obama was
he's not charming he's not charismatic
he's an old fuddy duddy
who can barely string together a
sentence and has been in washington
since well before i was born he also
happens to have some corruption problems
and he's
again unable to coherently speak i'd say
he doesn't have any of the
personal qualities that made barack
obama very popular particularly with
independence
but he does have the same thing that
obama did which is the promise
on which he gained office has now been
discarded the promise was returned to
normalcy we're going back to normal and
then he came in he's like what if i
spend 10 trillion dollars
10 trillion dollars what if i just do
that and talk about raising the capital
gains tax
radically and talk about raising income
tax rates and talk about regulating
everything under the sun via climate
change rules
what if i do all that and the american
people are like you know what i don't
like this
i don't like this republicans heading
into 2022 have to be very optimistic
about their chances
because here's the thing it ain't going
to get better for joe biden from here
joe biden's height of popularity is when
he took office and his first few hundred
his first hundred days that's when he's
gonna get the height of his popularity
americans already got their stemi checks
so that's it for that
americans are not going to like the
costs that are associated with what joe
biden has been pushing on the country
and that's why right now again his poll
numbers are not stellar
they're quite mediocre in fact and the
media are trying to cover up for that
fact that they're quite mediocre by
saying
that he has mostly positive marks but
the question is not whether he has
mostly positive marks
the question is where is he relative to
other presidents that not name donald
trump
at this time so in just one second we're
gonna get to the latest polling data
from washington post abc which shows
that joe biden is not a particularly
popular president
and this is going to have some pretty
significant downstream effects for
democrats who are running for congress
running for senate
in 2022 particularly in purple states
like georgia
okay so here are some of these poll
stats according to the washington post
52 percent of adults say they approve of
the job biden is doing compared with 42
who disapprove that's not a shock
because again he won about 52
of the vote nobody who voted for joe
biden is turning around and going oh i
hate that guy now
but he has not picked up a single
percentage point of support
from the rest and that's kind of
shocking because again
what polls tend to show people
self-reported polls particularly tend to
show that if you ask people
who they voted for after an election
they tend to say more often than they
actually voted for the person the person
who won
so normally in a normal circumstance if
you ask people how many of you voted for
joe biden and biden won
you get 60 of people saying they voted
for buy and even only 52 percent of
people
actually voted for biden well right now
his approval rating
mirrors precisely his actual voter
percentage
on the one hand you can say well that's
solid i mean it's consistent and that's
true it is solid and consistent
solid and consistent at a bare majority
which means there's a lot of room for
joe biden to slide and pretty much no
room for him to grow he now has a
ceiling his ceiling is about 52
he has no place to go but down from here
and as the effects of these
world breaking policies are felt it's
going to go down from here at this point
in his presidency four years ago
trump's rating was 42 percent
disapproval of 53 which again
was not a particular shock because he
only won 46 of the vote in 2016.
overall 34 of americans say they
strongly approve of biden's performance
35 say they strongly disapprove of
biden's performance
okay so he is running basically just
dead even
this by the way includes the fact that
he has huge marks for his handling of
covid
again i i struggle to see how joe biden
is going to gain from here
he's emerging from an economic
depression there's going to be a booming
economy for the next year
everybody knows that the stock market is
going bonkers
and people are going back to their
regular lives after they get vaccinated
and he's getting credit for that even
though he didn't do a damn thing about
it
i mean that's a pretty good position to
be sitting in normally in a vacuum you
say okay you got a president
with an economy that's about to boom at
like eight percent you have a
vaccine that has been tranched out at
the rate of 3 million a day to americans
and people going back to work you have
people going back to their regular lives
shouldn't that president be at like 75
approval rating
that ain't happening and the reason that
ain't happening is because this dude is
a partisan hack
and he is demonstrating that he is more
bernie sanders than
scoop jackson he's not an old-fashioned
moderate democrat he ain't joe manchin
he's closer to aoc than he is to a blue
dog democrat
53 percent of americans say they
disapprove of the way he has dealt with
the immigration
situation at the u.s mexico border which
by the way does not include aoc
right worthy of notes the people who
approve biden the most right now are
people like bernie sanders and alexander
ocasio-cortez
remember that time that alexander
ocasio-cortez got so upset with donald
trump's immigration policy and the kids
at the cages
that she actually went down to the
border in texas
and she put on a white outfit it was all
very spontaneous
she spontaneously decided to put on a
white outfit and then go stand outside
of an empty chain-link fence
and then stare across a parking lot and
she could maybe distantly see a facility
where there are kids being held in cages
and then stare directly into camera and
weep
remember this very spontaneous outburst
of emotion well now here's aoc
spontaneous outburst
of emotion a multiple of kids being held
in cages but you know joe biden's doing
a wonderful job
almost as though the democratic party
does not give a damn about the kids in
the cages they only care about who's in
power
i do think that um
[Music]
by demonstration and president biden has
definitely
exceeded expectations that progressives
had uh
you know i'll be fraying i think a lot
of us expected a much more conservative
administration
um and i think that his not only what
has ultimately come out but the active
invitation and willingness and
collaboration
uh with progressives in his first
100 days for almost 100 days
has been very impressive so i i take it
no weepy photo ops at the border then
none of that interesting interesting by
the way kamala harris
who is actually put in charge of the
border situation so far her
great accomplishment has been to you
know um well and also
she has well one thing she did was
well she goes on national tv she says
things are getting better at the border
without evidence that anything's getting
better at the border
in addition to meeting again with the
president of guatemala
i will be meeting the following day with
the community-based organizations in
guatemala they call them
basically civil society to figure out
how we can better assist what they're
doing on the ground
in a way again that they can give the
resources to people who naturally want
to stay at home
and give them some sense of hope that
help is on the way
this is the work that we're doing but
it's not going to be solved overnight
it's a complex issue
listen if this were easy it would have
been handled years ago
okay okay there's only one
whenever she has to say the hard part
that's when she starts laughing like
crazy person um
so i've noticed they haven't solved that
problem and the american people have
noticed this as well 53 percent of
americans
according to again this washington post
abc news poll say that they don't like
the way that he's dealing with the
border
his approval rating for the economy
stands at 52 now normally when you have
a booming economy like you're about to
get it should be in the 70s he's at 52
percent
and by the way if you look at it by the
democrat independent republican
breakdown
what you notice is that he's underwater
with independence he's at 47
with independence he's at 90 with
democrats which is why overall he's at
52 percent but he's at 40
47 with independence he is at
47 on the economy he's at 32
on immigration although his first
sizable initiatives enjoy majority
support the poll also finds that by two
to one
but americans say that biden should be
willing to make major changes to his
proposals to win republican support in
other words
the american people keep saying we
elected you to be a moderate and you are
not being a moderate
also 53 of americans say they are either
very or somewhat concerned that biden
will do too much to increase the size
and role of government you think
you think he's going to spend 10
trillion dollars that's his proposed
spending this year okay th this is
again pretty these are not great numbers
for joe biden
these are these are not stellar numbers
for joe biden in fact these are the
worst numbers except for donald trump
of any modern american president at this
point in time
it literally buried down in this
washington post article is the admission
that biden wins positive ratings ahead
of his 100th day better than trump
worse than every other president since
eisenhower at this point in time
obama was at 69 gw is at 63 bill clinton
was at 59
hw is at 71. reagan's at 73 cargo's at
63.
the the only person who
who has a lower rating um and and it's
not net
right only only just in absolute terms
was journaled four but even he had a
plus 16 rating
biden's at plus 10 but normally
presidents are
like plus 40 plus 30 plus 20 plus 50.
if you go all the way back to like
eisenhower kennedy and johnson plus 70.
okay so this is not a popular president
by any stretch of the imagination i know
that the
the media want to cram down on you the
idea that what joe biden is doing is
very popular but that's because
they are completely try they're trying
to pretend there is no disconnect
between what joe biden wants to do and
what he was elected to do and that
disconnect is going
growing broader and broader every single
day and this is giving republicans a
real opening
and if republicans cannot ram this home
by 2022 that will be a failure on their
part a massive failure on their part you
can see
that democrats are already starting to
realize what a disaster some of this
radicalism is
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist tier
that is just science
[Music]
ugh